buongiorno
grazie buongiorno a tutti oggi si parla
di origini noi oggi abbiamo un origine
quando nasciamo e quando nasce domani un
bambino dove nasce in italia nasce in
una democrazia questa è la nostra
origine notri cercheremo di capire che
cosa può succedere che cosa possiamo
fare per preservare preservare le nostre
la nostra situazione oggi noi diamo per
scontato magari questa condizione
votiamo abbiamo delle istituzioni che
proteggono la nostra libertà la nostra
vita le nostre istanze con tutte le
imperfezioni però abbiamo una
caratteristica che è quella di poter
vivere in un sistema democratico che
cerca di dare risposte ai cittadini non
tutti i paesi oggi nel mondo vivono
questa condizione qua trovate i diversi
gradi di stato di democrazia all'interno
del mondo quindi dai sistemi meno
democratici e sistemi che vengono
considerati dagli osservatori
internazionali più vicini all'ideale di
democrazia come potete vedere la
situazione democratica nel mondo non è
uguale per tutti quindi non tutte le
persone possono accedere agli stessi
diritti che caratteristica la democrazia
un principio quello dell'accountability
una parola difficilissima da tradurre in
italiano ma che cerca di cerco di
spiegarmi cosa significa essere account
ball vuol dire rispondere a qualcuno sa
qualcosa in un'organizzazione in uno
stato in un sistema di organizzazioni
complesse significa rispondere a
qualcuno quindi in un sistema
democratico se qualcosa non funziona se
crediamo che i nostri governanti non
siano adeguati noi dovremmo riuscire a
poterli
togliere poter sostituirli con altre
persone quindi con dei sistemi di
accountability questa è un po la
caratteristica di qualunque democrazia
evoluta ci sono delle buone notizie che
rispettano la storia degli ultimi
decenni attraverso i sistemi democratici
e soprattutto attraverso tre elementi la
tecnologia la democrazia il commercio
siamo riusciti nell'ultimo secolo ad
avanzare fortemente in tantissimi
indicatori economico sociali che
caratterizzano l'esistenza di ogni
persona e delle società pensiamo alla si
parla spesso del problema della fame nel
mondo la fame nel mondo quindi hunger è
diminuita a livello percentuale a
livello di valore assoluto in tutto il
mondo questo è stato possibile
attraverso l'implementazione tecnologica
attraverso il commercio tra paesi
attraverso una maturità dei paesi e
delle organizzazioni nel dare soluzioni
e risposte alle persone
lo stesso è accaduto per la povertà
estrema povertà estrema una condizione
in cui una persona non può permettersi
di mangiare di accedere a elementi
diciamo di sussistenza la povertà
estrema negli ultimi anni è diminuita
sia a livello percentuale quindi
rispetto alla popolazione che
chiaramente è cresciuta sia a livello di
valore assoluto quindi il numero di
persone che vivono in povertà estrema è
sensibilmente diminuito questo però cosa
significa che non è detto che questo
trend continui a rimanere tale ci sono
state dei fattori esogeni che possono
avere anche invertito la rotta quindi
questo lo vedremo nei prossimi anni però
questo è un ulteriore indicatore
positivo che magari non sempre viene
percepito ma che di nuovo risponde ad
un'evoluzione dei mezzi tecnologici di
commercio di politica e di democrazia
che le società stanno le società stanno
cercando di portare avanti un ultimo
punto è quello del commercio noi anche
oggi la nostra origine soprattutto di
chi è più giovane è quella di vivere in
un contesto di pace diciamo l'europa si
è fatta la guerra per tantissimo tempo e
anche all'interno dei conflitti
internazionali i mondiali ci sono state
guerre praticamente in tutto il mondo
per secoli oggi noi ci siamo abituati ad
avere un'origine di pace questo anche
grazie al sistema di commercio
internazionale quando due paesi tra i
paesi 10 paesi 20 paesi si fanno la si
fanno una guerra non hanno beneficio di
commercio mentre quando i paesi
commerciano tra di loro si riduce
sensibilmente
l'incentivo a creare un conflitto questo
non significa azzerarlo completamente ma
statisticamente viene ridotta la
percentuale di probabilità che due paesi
si possano fare la guerra questo perché
non c'è un interesse reciproco se il
paese che colpisco perde soldi
popolazione e ricchezza non commercial a
più con me e magari non comprerà più il
mio debito pubblico non avrò più scambi
finanziari e questo è uno dei motivi per
cui si sia cercato nei i 70 anni di
incentivare con dei sistemi che
potessero dare l'opportunità a tutti
anche il commercio internazionale
tuttavia non è detto che questa origine
in cui noi viviamo oggi che viviamo
tutti i giorni
credendo che sia diciamo magari a
normalità soprattutto perchè è più
giovane non possa invertirsi
la storia insegna che ci sono stati dei
casi di paesi di regione nel mondo in
cui si è arrivati ad uno stadio di
democrazia di benessere sociale di
libertà e poi questo stadio è stato
invertito stato invertito per rivolta è
stato invertito per fattori esogeni
magari una forte carestia una
problematica climatica una problematica
di fattori esterni o interni a una
popolazione può far degenerare lo stato
e farlo tornare indietro a questo è
successo in moltissimi paesi ed è il
motivo per cui noi oggi come cittadini
attivi possiamo mantenere i nostri occhi
aperti e cercare di evitare di invertire
di mantenere la nostra origine e cercare
di farla evolvere ulteriormente non
soltanto in italia ma in tutto il mondo
ci sono tre strumenti e 3 metodologie
che vengono utilizzati che possono
essere utilizzati oggi per proteggere
questa nostra regione per proteggere le
democrazie cercare di rafforzarle la
prima è quella dell'innovazione innovare
cosa significa fare le cose in modo
diverso
oggi si possono fare tante cose antiche
con l'uso e lo strumento della
tecnologia quindi l'innovazione è fare
le cose utilizzando magari dei metodi e
degli strumenti o delle risorse che sono
differenti rispetto alla storia è
l'altro elemento è quello della
trasparenza che andremo a vedere perché
oggi parliamo di questo perché le
democrazie a cui noi ci stiamo abituando
sappiamo che possono in qualunque
momento essere in pericolo e comunque
vanno preservate questo è il bilancio
dello stato di taiwan
ovviamente la lingua non è facilmente
comprensibile però quello che è
facilmente comprensibile è la grafica
questo tipo di strumento viene
utilizzato attraverso delle infografiche
per raccontare ai cittadini che cosa sta
succedendo all'interno dello stato sto
spendendo in salita sto spendendo in
difesa sto utilizzando queste risorse si
può cliccare vedere in che cosa viene
utilizzata una risorsa pubblica in un
modo o nell'altro
e questo permette al cittadino
attraverso la tecnologia di comprendere
meglio come sta lavorando la sua
democrazia e attraverso il sistema
dell'accountability decidere valutare in
modo consapevole se questi governanti
che abbiamo selezionato o a volte non
abbiamo selezionato rispondono alle
nostre esigenze noi riteniamo che
possano essere adatti a governare questo
invece è un file xml perché qua non è
super nerd
probabilmente non conosceva questo tipo
di file è il file che viene utilizzato
nel mondo delle democrazie nelle
pubbliche amministrazioni per raccontare
con codice il sistema degli appalti
delle delibere e così via quindi oggi
noi cosa potremmo capire da questo file
praticamente nulla e queste sono un po i
piccoli pericoli che si annidano
all'interno anche di democrazie evolute
come l'italia e che possono influenzare
in qualche modo la mancanza di accesso
alle informazioni se noi non abbiamo
accesso alle informazioni in modo
semplificato come abbiamo visto prima
potremmo come cittadini non aver accesso
a una consapevolezza nostra rispetto a
come sta andando il nostro sistema
democratico
per questa ragione sono stati creati
tantissimi sistemi per accedere a queste
informazioni
questo per esempio un pdf di un bilancio
pubblico anche il pdf non è
semplicissimo da comprendere perché
perché un pdf non può essere aggregato
con più pdf è un file diciamo liscio
quindi non è possibile
sommare per esempio questi dati con
altri dati di altri pdf e per un
giornalista per un membro
dell'opposizione per un cittadino comune
questo tipo di file risultano molto
blindati di nuovo potrebbe essere un
problema per i sistemi democratici non
permette alle persone di accedere a
questi dati in maniera consapevole
quindi che cosa succede tante
organizzazioni si stanno attrezzando per
rendere facilmente visualizzabili i dati
dei governi dei sistemi democratici e
delle amministrazioni locali perché
anche i piccoli comuni gestiscono
risorse pubbliche con dei sistemi di
accountability e comunicando quello che
stanno facendo con dei file così
incompressibili magari possono rischiare
di non dare accesso a tutte le
informazioni e quindi in questo modo
tecnologia innovazione e trasparenza
si uniscono per dare delle risposte ed
evitare che possano verificarsi
degli annebbiamenti della democrazia
perché dove manca l'informazione il
rischio che appunto i cittadini non
possono essere in grado di esprimere poi
consapevolmente il proprio voto che è
l'elemento più importante che protegge
la nostra origine democratica qua vedete
un altro ulteriore elemento invece che
riguarda la tecnologia è proprio quella
che l'innovazione
il paese della thailandia la thailandia
alcuni anni fa ha prodotto una politica
pubblica che si chiama thailand for po
in giro che sostanzialmente andava a
fornire a tutti i cittadini delle
informazioni rispetto a come utilizzare
la tecnologia e l'innovazione per
guadagnare per uscire dalla cosiddetta
trappola della povertà che quella
situazione che viene studiata dagli
economisti in cui in tanti paesi tante
persone rimangono in una classe diciamo
basta e non riescono a scavalcare questo
livello ed è un tema che gli economisti
adorano perché cercano dire ma come
facciamo a far uscire queste persone da
questa trappola della povertà che è
difficilissima da aprire la tecnologia
può essere uno strumento quindi cosa
succede un po di anni fa arriva all e
commerce arriva il mondo del web e tante
persone e tante aziende dicono dio
questa questa tecnologia mi ruberà il
lavoro rischio di andare in bancarotta e
quel governo invece dice no attenzione
cerchiamo di utilizzare la tecnologia a
scopo di far guadagnare queste persone
questi piccoli imprenditori e quindi
iniziano a trasmettere nelle televisioni
pubbliche locali e nazionali dei corsi
sei un imprenditore un piccolo
imprenditore una piccola artigiano che
fa le trecce di fiori secchi non
venderle per la strada di bangkok vendi
le a una coppia in california che deve
sposarsi magari li utilizzerà come
bomboniere che così guadagni dieci volte
tanto
oppure sei un imprenditore che produce
elementi di agricoltura ci sono dei
sistemi che ti permettono di fare
ecommerce e di venderli ad una
popolazione più lontana dei turisti così
via quello è far empowerment quindi
potenziamento per proteggere le persone
per proteggere la loro condizione di
diciamo economica e far avanzare la
l'origine in questo caso cioè portarli a
uscire dalla trappola della povertà e
noi sappiamo che dove si diciamo dove
cresce la ricchezza e il rischio di
rivolta democratica e di inversione
della democrazia è sicuramente minore
questo paese bellissimo innevato invece
è l'estonia l'estonia si è trovata a
vivere in uno stadio di transizione cosa
significa quando un economia in
transizione significa che è passata
attraverso una grande evoluzione o
rivoluzione economico sociale o storica
l'estonia provenendo dall'unione
sovietica si è trovata come tanti paesi
a dover cambiare tutti i sistemi sisters
i politici i sistemi economici qualunque
cosa e queste rivoluzioni possono essere
impattanti quindi come ogni grande
trasformazione possono esserci vincitori
e vinti e la l'estonia che cos'ha fatto
ha deciso di utilizzare la tecnologia
per
proteggere e favorire la democrazia a
favore dei cittadini qui è diventato lo
stato più innovativo più tecnologico
sostanzialmente del mondo oggi l'estonia
a circa il 99,9 per cento di tutti gli
adempimenti burocratici per qualunque
attività di un cittadino aprire
un'azienda a pagare le tasse chiedere un
certificato qualunque cosa già da quasi
vent'anni è tutto assolutamente online
in questo modo loro che cosa hanno fatto
hanno cercato di favorire una crescita
tecnologica di tutto il paese quindi
alle scuole delle aziende della
cittadinanza attrarre imprese e fare in
modo che la popolazione potesse vivere
in una condizione democratica a loro
favorevole anche in questo caso
l'obiettivo principale è proteggere la
democrazia e fare in modo che le persone
possano stare il meglio possibile
questo è la crescita che ha avuto il
paese se noi consideriamo altri paesi
dell'area baltica o altri paesi che
provengono dalla stessa storia politica
della dell'estonia non esistono diciamo
gradi comparabili a questo tipo di
crescita chiaramente nessun paese
perfetto anche in questi paesi che hanno
utilizzato la tecnologia trasparenza
l'innovazione per proteggere la loro
origine democratica possono annidarsi
situazioni di distorsioni di qualunque
tipo sociali politiche economiche però
abbiamo evidenza dall analisi delle
politiche pubbliche che questi elementi
di trasparenza di innovazione e
tecnologia possono effettivamente creare
degli effetti positivi quindi riguardano
la pace il commercio la crescita socio
economica e la protezione stessa della
democrazia
perché ci interessa proteggere la
democrazia è uno dei development goal
uno degli obiettivi di sostenibilità
oltre all'ambiente
l'abbassamento del rischio di fame e
tutti quegli elementi di cui magari oggi
finalmente le giorno sui giornali c'è
questo sedicesimo obiettivo che p strong
jones in strong institutions permettere
alle persone di vivere sempre di più e
sempre più persone di vivere in
condizioni di istituzioni democratiche
che possano proteggere la loro vita e la
loro libertà
che cosa possiamo fare noi che questo è
un po il il punto poi più importante
anche se noi oggi viviamo e siamo
abituati ad una condizione di democrazia
di pace nonostante ci possano essere
magari dei segnali da tutto il mondo che
questo possa cambiare da un momento
all'altro noi abbiamo un grande potere
oggi ci sono degli strumenti qua ce ne
sono alcuni che permettono ai cittadini
di essere cittadini attivi di essere
delle antenne della democrazia e
proteggere e continuare a sostenere
questa che la nostra origine più
importante all'interno di questo paese
il foglia è un diritto che i cittadini
possono esercitare nella accedere a
informazioni pubbliche volete sapere
come viene assegnato uno spazio di un
teatro ad un'associazione a voi potete
fare esercitare questo diritto a
chiedere al comune alla regione a
qualunque ente come è stato fatto questo
processo che è stato selezionato con
quali risorse e questo ovviamente per un
cittadino comune può essere interessante
ma pensate per un giornalista un membro
di una organizzazione non governativa
un'associazione insomma tutti quei
signori tutti quegli attori che vengono
considerati watch dog cioè cani da
guardia delle democrazie che sono
soggetti più qualificati per loro
esperienza a monitorare che tutto stia
proseguendo bene l'accesso agli altri
agli atti è un altro elemento che tutti
i cittadini possono esercitare voi
potete chiedere all'amministrazione
conto di qualunque scelta pubblica
quindi un concorso una una delibera
qualunque elemento con un una procedura
molto semplice si trovano su google sono
delle e mail
buongiorno vorrei sapere questa cosa e
loro devono rispondere entro un tot di
giorni se non viene data risposta può
esserci una procedimento amministrativo
di solito rispondono quindi anche questo
è un altro atto molto importante
whistleblowing è una parola un po strana
vuol dire fischiettare è una nuova legge
che permetterà a partire dal prossimo
anno a tutte le persone delle
organizzazioni private e pubbliche di
poter segnalare degli eventuali anomalie
in modo anonimo quindi io non voglio
andare a denunciare alla procura in un
contesto magari che può anche
spaventarmi una presunta anomalia magari
non sono neanche tanto sicuro che quella
sia un'anomalia magari credo che ci sia
stato un problema di un concorso
truccato credo che ci sia stato un
problema su una persona che non era
adatta a quel ruolo diciamo un problema
di democrazia
come posso segnalarlo si in un'azienda
privata se in un'azienda pubblica
attraverso questi sistemi di questo
blogging che quindi sono dei software
che permettono in modo anonimo di fare
segnalazioni e questo permette a dei
soggetti terzi di verificare che cosa è
successo anche in questo caso significa
non voltarsi dall'altra parte perché
quando una persona si abitua qualunque
contesto vive nella sua zona di confort
quello il momento più pericoloso
perché possano invertirsi i fattori e
quindi invertire la nostra origine e
tornare ad uno stadio quindi precedente
alla nostra regina democratica e poi in
ultimo sostenere giornalisti attivisti
persone che possono fare veramente la
guardia alla democrazia senza mai dare
per scontato che questo stadio che
abbiamo raggiunto possa non essere mai
invertito però abbiamo al nostro interno
dei sistemi diciamo di accountability
che dovrebbero permetterci di proteggere
il più possibile
in sostanza in pochissime parole anzi in
tre parole noi possiamo proteggere i
nostri sistemi democratici con la
tecnologia con la trasparenza con
l'innovazione ma soprattutto essendo
cittadini attivi che vuol dire
informarsi vuol dire avere un'antenna
accesa nei confronti dei nostri sistemi
di potere e nei confronti di tutti gli
attori che governano insieme a noi le
democrazie quindi il mondo
dell'informazione il mondo della
politica della giustizia
e così via e questo sarà il nostro modo
per mantenere
assolutamente immutata questa nostra
origine così preziosa grazie
[Applauso]